foreign
Dayton OH
as you get by the way Marsh could
already tell when it's a damn video just
by the floors we know those guys floors
already
so Dayton hypernova dude I this floor
gives me anxiety
is it all the Dayton leavens yeah man
like look all the flakes all the dating
flakes like look my cat my cats have
these little corrugated cardboard
scratcher things right because they love
those things right and it's annoying
because they scratch them and eventually
these little pieces of cardboard that
you have to vacuum up it's annoying
right I have to run my vacuum all the
time which is annoying but like dude
clean I did that would drive me
insane I like I haven't had hardwood
floors in a long time and you kind of
forget how like quick in the corners
like without carpet you see things so
you break out the [ __ ] Dust Buster or
something this guy just this guy's never
operated a dustbusters so busy doing
laundry
oh title my transphobic snob of a mom
trash talks to a visitor of a house
about me concerning myself over cat
condescendingly about God I mean trying
to find my cat or she's going to claim
it to be her cat probably the moment I
say that I want to take the cat with me
if I ever move out probably she'll say
lots
I'm not a second version if I ever move
out if he ever does I mean here's the
thing Dayton right that your daddy's
dying your mom is probably gonna she
lost her son and her husband she's
probably not going to be long for this
world you're going to lose your mommy
um you can't stay there forever pal even
if you and if you think that you're
going to inherit that place your sister
and your brother-in-law are probably 100
because they took care of them yeah and
they helped out and they were part of
the family so
um you're gonna have to get the [ __ ] out
someday Bud then what are you gonna do
he
I think we're going to have the day this
Dayton Saga will be will be a homeless
Dayton Saga one way or the other where
it's going to be an atrostia level
videos that's going to come start coming
out it's my cat but she just now
basically said that the cat is my cat so
anyway that's mine he's dressed like
he's gonna sell [ __ ] estrogen on the
street corner
it's my cat not hers how much you want
to bet that
they buy the cat food that they change
the litter box that they take but it's
his cat I guarantee it you think he's
buying what money yeah definitely I
started recording she was talking to by
the way that [ __ ] [ __ ] adds up that
[ __ ] adds up real quick let me grab that
dude that [ __ ] adds up real quick
[ __ ] so I know he ain't paying for it
for Thanksgiving
um uh like he was saying is talking
about how the cat went missing and I
played all these signs for the cat your
dad's dying of cancer
like somebody's running down all this
stuff and Drew her face on and
everything like I made all these signs
yeah like missing cats you're 36 doing
arts and crafts that doesn't make it
your cat signs and you know uh and I put
them all around the neighborhood I was
fan of a couple of days because the cat
was missing like 48 hours so anyway
I put them all over the neighborhood in
a span of days
you should be able to get a bunch of
missing cat fires up in the neighborhood
in like two hours tops on this whole
spiel about you know you know how I was
so concerned about the cat that went
missing because she left the door open
um not the front door open and doesn't
the screen door doesn't shut on the
front door so it's like if the front
door is open or if it's not even locked
it can open so if it's not locked
you should Mumble more about the lock
said
the house I can't get it I don't see it
there's a rainbow flag over there though
there's actually two rainbow Flags one
like he's still going on about the
rainbow flags that his sister has yes
one on their Front Street two isn't
enough
over their front door and there's like
on their front step area and there's one
yeah yes yes because on gay holidays you
have to put a flag over your thing or a
drag queen will come in a molester kit
everybody knows that yeah
my mom's transphobic and the rainbow
Flags they hit me and ghost ghost
brother caused me a [ __ ] he is like
he's losing it man yeah he's like he's
getting worse I think his enemies like
his main enemy's been gone and he's been
kind of ruined and he's gonna lose his
dad and he slowly as these people die
he's still going to be bitching about
him long after they're gone and that's
gonna be the [ __ ] that's the chapter
I'm looking forward to remember he was
[ __ ] on the painting of his dead
brother that his mom had me yes
the house rainbow Flags to to basically
over under is that after his dad passes
the mom keeps the house and doesn't just
sell it
I mean the mom might sell the house I
mean that's not a bad that's not a bad
thing you're right the mom might just
sell the house and probably the sister
be like we just come live with us mom
you know
or other way around the sister moves in
there
right there neighbors and just to
Gaslight them about anything they may
have heard about the trans violence
happening in the house across the street
with a razor like there are kids nobody
cares about you dating everyone that
meets you hates you
everyone every person that I've talked
to that's ever interacted with you hates
you raised half the time yes or from
like my parents babysitting we've never
met him
and we hate him yeah crazy violence is
happening to me I think Ashley they're
neighbors with that if they're like
making it look like they're real
supporters of like trans people and both
of my uh both my my sister and her why
wouldn't you want to support this why
would you want to support a rambling
lunatic who's up in the bed talking
about his dead brother and his dad's
dying of cancer complaining they're not
paying enough to do laundry because he
lives there for free why would anybody
hate trans people like you
there's really no way to know so can you
explain to me why trans people hate you
the entire [ __ ] gay community in
Dayton hates him like you know they have
one of those you know
you know the the what what's it called
when a bunch of gay people get together
a Molly of gays I don't know but a
school a school well no they shouldn't
be near those but well that's probably
why they call it that oh okay yeah
both are physically harassment there is
a word for a bundle of gays but you
can't say it
it's here they both physically shoved me
around they're very large people they're
like built like football players or like
really large they're both obese who it's
family though your cancer-ridden
octogenarian father but like Michael
Strahan or your weak old lady mom that
we've seen Warren sapsized no we've seen
them oh you're right the only big one
was his brother was a big dude yeah he
was
and they're very tall people and my
sister's only about it [ __ ] it's like my
sister's five foot seven she was only
about an inch or so like about an inch
um shorter than me I guess so like
she physically shoved me around very
large basketball player size and her
husband's like a little bit smaller than
her he physically shoved me around with
her they both showed me around about
talking about the skinhead and my the
words of my uh brother-in-law would hey
maybe I don't know they probably didn't
really show him around but if they did
maybe it's because you're sick of you
[ __ ] on their [ __ ] dead brother
you thought maybe you're the Dane have
you ever looked in the mirror and said
you're the well you can't look in the
mirror it's so dirty but like clean the
mirror and maybe you're the problem
was
um I couldn't understand why he would
hate your guts and I'm like why would
anyone hate my guts why would anybody
hate my guts
is there anyone that like ever leaves
positive comments or feedback on his
stuff
well this has 14 views and it's unlisted
but on Facebook does he talk like is he
just yeah talking to nobody uh well no
there there is like three or four people
hold on actually I could probably help
you with this because so I I don't want
to say who's helping me obviously
because I have a couple people helping
me but I obviously thank you but I can't
say who it is obviously because
we don't want the stream to stop but uh
Kate Paradox all right I got paid
tonight for this week and then and the
skip the week before actually honorable
thing my mom did today she now owes me 4
500 up from 2020 last year wait let me
bring it up again uh at least this money
can afford me to visit my Andy Warhol
mom during winter
wait a minute let me let me ask
something
so
you get a hundred dollars a week right
so you didn't get paid for 45 weeks out
of 52 weeks in 2020
I guess not but you know what this is a
good point like nobody I'm looking at
his post nobody likes them
you know
this uh uh I always get uh
about me at best I also haven't talked
to the guitarist in our music scene who
entirely Vibes with me oh they hit him
oh God's right they also hate him in the
music scene and because remember he
plays guitar
so they also hate him there does it not
[ __ ] get through to you bud
I mean like I can't imagine
just getting to this point in life
and ever everyone who's ever met me
despises me I would be like man maybe I
need a holy [ __ ] like I'm gonna be
completely alone but this guy doesn't
get it he doesn't get it
he's the [ __ ] and why doesn't he ever
talk about that he's because because it
would [ __ ] up his whole like basically
his whole Narrative of my family treats
me like [ __ ] even though they really
take very good care of them my family
treats me like [ __ ] but it's because
they're transphobes they're this they're
that so you he he won't bring up the
fact that the gay community or I'm sure
the very left-leaning music community in
Dayton Ohio like also don't like him why
don't you talk about that bud